au milieu des années 80 je me souviens
que nous avions à la maison une grosse
télé blanche les utilise volontairement
le terme grosse parce que le téléviseur
était gros mais l'écran lui était tout
petit bombay en noir et blanc et
certainement pas en haute définition
néanmoins sur cet écran j'ai vu pour la
première fois des enfants éthiopiens qui
mouraient de faim et sur cet écran j'ai
aussi vu pour la première fois la vidéo
de michael jackson et lionel richie le
we made you were le premier grand tube
pour collecter des fonds et se battre
contre la famine dans le monde
dans les trente dernières années
heureusement nous avons fait d'immenses
progrès la famine dans le monde a
énormément reculé et les téléviseurs
vous en avez tous un chez vous sont
désormais ultra plat hd en couleurs mais
le progrès me donne l'impression
d'avancer toujours un peu en zigzag
si les téléviseurs aujourd'hui ont une
technologie très avancée et de qualité
les programmes télévisés eux n'ont
vraisemblablement pas suivi le pas et si
la famine a nettement reculé dans le
monde
aujourd'hui nous avons à faire face aux
problèmes opposés qui est celui de
l'obésité aujourd'hui dans le monde
il y a plus de personnes obèses que de
personnes qui meurent de faim l'obésité
c'est 12% de la population mondiale 15%
de la population française et on estime
qu'en 2030
un français sur deux sera obèses
l'obésité c'est pas qu'un problème de
poids
l'obésité c'est principalement un
problème de maladie associé des maladies
qui sont engendrées par ce surpoids et
qui détruisent la vie des patients elle
détériore énormément leur qualité de vie
et elle est courte l'espérance de vie
des patients obèses les patients obèses
ont une espérance de vie diminuer par
rapport aux autres
l'obésité reconnaît plusieurs causes des
facteurs génétiques des facteurs
socio-économiques des facteurs culturels
facteurs agroalimentaire on dit qu'elle
est multifactorielle et c'est ce qui
rend probablement cette obésité
difficiles à traiter
mais le progrès de ces trente dernières
années s'est aussi intéressé à la
médecine en particulier à la chirurgie
avec le développement de techniques
chirurgicales qu'on appelle chirurgie de
l'obésité ou chirurgie bariatrique ce
qui est un peu plus compliquée et ses
chirurgies qui ont comme objectif de
limiter les apports et parfois même de
limiter l'absorption des aliments ont
connu un boom formidable parce que non
seulement elles permettent une perte de
poids quasi miraculeuse mais surtout une
amélioration et parfois même une
disparition des maladies associées à
l'obésité
elles permettent donc une amélioration
de la qualité de vie et un rallongement
de l'espérance de vie des patients
opérés néanmoins l'obésité étant
multifactorielle et complexe
nous faisons face aujourd'hui à beaucoup
d'échec de ces chirurgies des échecs en
termes de perte de points insuffisante
des échecs pour des reprises de poids
réapparition des maladies associées et
détérioration de la qualité de vie à la
base de l'obésité je crois qu'il ya
toujours et avant tout un problème de
comportement alimentaire et un
comportement qu'est ce que c'est et bien
c'est une façon de s'adapter à un milieu
et ce milieu
lequel est il et bien c'est le vôtre
c'est le mien c'est la société de
consommation
est ce un hasard si le buzz it et qui
frappe principalement les pays
développés et les pays en voie de
développement
frappe ce pays où les troubles
psychiatriques ont la plus grande
incidence et où le traitement de ces
troubles psychiatriques représente l'une
des plus grosses dépenses de santé les
troubles du comportement alimentaire
cette société de consommation qu'est ce
qu'elle nous un culte
elle essaye de nous faire croire que la
consommation d'objets pourrait avoir un
rôle salvateur que la consommation
d'objets et d'objets toujours nouveau
pourrait nous permettre de calmer nos
pulsions de calmer nos désirs mais s'est
vraiment passé à côté de l'essence même
des pulsions et des désirs qui sont
infinies et cette consommation infinie
d'objets et d'objets toujours nouveau
fini par consommer le consommateur il ya
une analogie affaires intéressantes avec
les addictions avec les consommations de
substances consommation de substances
qui tente de pallier à ses pulsions ou à
ses émotions et qui finissent par
détériorer de façon très importante la
vie de ces personnes j'ai eu la chance
inouïe de pratiquer les chirurgies
d'apprendre les chirurgie de l'obésité
avec certains des meilleurs chirurgiens
au monde des pionniers de la chirurgie
bariatrique
j'ai donc appris à maîtriser les
techniques d'une façon optimale
mais ce qui a vraiment changé ma
carrière c'est d'avoir voulu envisager
l'obésité différemment d'avoir voulu
considérer l'obésité non plus comme une
maladie mais comme un symptôme dans ce
sens de voir le patient obèse comme une
victime de son milieu non pas une
victime passive parce que il faut
fournir un effort énorme pour être
obèses puis pour supporter le poids son
surpoids
pensez-y
se lever prendre une douche monter dans
un bus ramener les courses à la maison
jouer avec ses enfants sont des efforts
quotidiens pour ces personnes et le
patient obèse vit cette situation
paradoxale où il est à la fois la
victime et son propre bourreau
face à l'importance des troubles du
comportement alimentaire dans cette
pathologie et grâce à une équipe
exceptionnelle motivée et compétente
nous avons tenté d'évaluer l'efficacité
d'outils de travail sur le comportement
alimentaire en un monde et chirurgie de
l'obésité
nous avons donc élaboré des outils que
nous avons proposé à nos patients et
avec un peu de recul
nous avons vu que ces outils
lorsqu'ils sont adaptés lorsqu'ils sont
simples à mettre en oeuvre
lorsqu'ils répondent aux exigences des
patients
ils permettent quelque chose de
formidable ces patients qui expérimente
ses outils finissent par se les
approprier et en faire leurs propres
moyens de fonctionnement
il trouve donc un nouveau moyen de
fonctionnement
il élabore un nouveau comportement dans
leur milieu
ça se traduit généralement par une
petite perte de poids mais totalement
involontaire sans effort et non
seulement une perte de poids mais aussi
un grand gain de confiance
ça m'a fait penser parce que j'ai vu un
documentaire sur sa aux perles de
culture et j'ai l'impression que cela
ressemble à ces élevages de perles ou le
chirurgien ou l'opérateur dans ce cas
insère dans l'huître un greffon et c'est
l'huître qui va progressivement
construire sa nouvelle perle
face à ce patient perles le geste
technique de greffe chirurgicale passe
un peu en second plan le chirurgien ne
fabrique pas la perle
mais il met l'huître dans les meilleures
conditions pour pouvoir la fabriquer
face à certaines critiques qui
pourraient surgir
quant à la chirurgie en ce deuxième
position je tiens à dire deux choses la
première c'est qu'il ne s'agit pas de
réduire l'utilité de la chirurgie mais
il s'agit plutôt de mettre en avant
l'utilité du patient de son travail dans
ce changement et ce genre de travail
avec les patients sur le comportement
alimentaire permet aux médecins de
retrouver le sens même de sa vocation
ce qu'il a cherché tout au long de ses
études
ce que ses amis certains de ses amis lui
envient c'est à dire le fait de prendre
soin de personnes dans la souffrance
d'accompagner des personnes dans la
guérison
non pas de s'occuper tout simplement de
la maladie mais de s'occuper du malade
en effet on a beau vouloir et avoir les
moyens techniques pour faire des perles
ce n'est jamais sans la collaboration de
l'huître